[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here is walking on Sunset
victory for Gary deneker is the BBC
backs down over the match of the day
Mutiny but is it a victory for free
speech or just a spectacular own goal by
the national broadcaster or maybe both
statues of able-bodied white men should
be torn down in case they're racist
according to the Welsh government
because they're brushing the past really
make anything better in the present
we'll debate that plus
what does it feel like to be in Glass
Onion well I'm barely in it I'm in it
for about three seconds yeah all right
back to you guys
a few grants breathtaking arrogance
becomes the biggest talking point on the
beige carpet at a decidedly beige Oscars
should we ban Hugh Grant from all Awards
ceremonies to make them more interesting
Sharon Osborne joins me live
from London the is Piers Morgan
uncensored well Canadian from London
welcome to Pierce Morgan uncensored Gary
lineker stood his ground against a
howling mob demanding his head over an
honestly held opinion he also stood his
ground against his employers at the BBC
as it tied itself in knots of chaos and
hypocrisy it took on a staggering six
days to resolve Jug's gate six days of
turmoil rescuing the entirety of the BBC
Sports coverage and the future of his
management over a single tweet
expressing an opinion and the net
results of the whole foragos or very
angry people and a battered BBC
reputation that will pay the price for a
lot longer than six days I'm not sure
what director General Tim Davey is
looking quite so smug about
one of the joys of this affair is
there'd never been an easy solution but
asking Gary to step back off air was I
think a significant thing and now we
look forward with this agreement moving
forward to resolve things and get back
to business as usual
I thought there was much joy in this
whole Affair Mr Dave you match the day
bizarrely Ed with no pundits or
commentary at the weekend after a host
of stars pulled out in support of the
Nikka Sports coverage across the BBC
descended a complete fast as
pre-recorded podcasts and filler took
the place of some of his most popular
shows and that's why the BBC's really
backed down it was about to lose one of
his biggest stars obliterating his
reputation in the process they couldn't
even put together a convincing argument
for why any of this was happening none
of the people bang for lenica's blood
have been able to explain why he's any
different to the many other contractors
who frequently Express opinions like
Apprentice host Alan sugar who blasted
Jeremy corbyn on the front page of the
Sun and made other rather unfortunate
inappropriate jokes well Jeremy Clarkson
when he was hosted Top Gear said
striking public sector workers should be
shot or Andrew Neal who was a BBC star
interviewer and politics host for
decades same time as running The
Spectator
all of these people continued their work
for the BBC along with sir David
Attenborough who talks very stridently
about things like climate change because
audiences like them and they were able
to see the blinding the obvious
difference between the BBC's editorial
stance and the personal views of some of
the people who work for them the entire
Saga has shown an unflattering light on
the BBC Tim Davey looks hapless
perfectly straightforward rules about
impartiality have become an unsolvable
riddle and questions are now
intensifying of the future of chairman
Richard Sharp a conservative donor who
organized a massive loan for Boris
Johnson just before the same Boris
Johnson gave him a job but more than
anything he shot a light unflatteringly
on some weapons grade Hypocrites many of
the people crusading volinica's sacking
have found themselves caught up in the
toxic swirl of canceled culture they've
normally professed to hate the BBC could
have made a powerful statement for free
speech and Common Sense by backing them
again from the beginning instead it's
become well a spectacular own goal well
joining me now is the leader of the true
and fair party Gina Miller and reform UK
leader and talk to you presenter Richard
Tice I'm also joined by Chief of the
writer of the times Henry Winter let me
start with you Henry always a voice of
Common Sense the enemy of Hysteria as
all around lose their heads
um what's your overview of where we've
washed up on lineage gate
well I think that the broader
perspective is that we should be able to
have grown up conversations in this
country and uh if the government and the
BBC bosses are convinced that a sports
present uh articulating a tweet not a
terribly toxic and I didn't agree with
his language on the 30s but you know
he's he's an intelligent individual he's
traveled the world his experience is
quite capable of coming out with a
reasoned argument he's not presenting
the 10 o'clock news so there was no
issue with impartiality but I think
we've seen the best of the the BBC and
the worst of the BBC the best of the BBC
is you're alluding to is the support of
sheer rights and so many other people
for Ian Wright and this is what Tim
Davian this is the worst of the BBC is
the the naivety and arrogance and
entitlement of the bosses upstairs how
out of touch I mean I've talked to so
many BBC staff over the weekend sports
stuff over the weekend who said the
management just so out of touch you
can't do that in any business yours mine
certainly not at the BBC so I think Tim
Davies being brought back from America
has been brought back down to earth he's
been reminded that there is this
Collective spirit in his Sports
department so they've come out of it
incredibly well but management really
got to learn some basic skills yeah I
mean and the most extraordinary aspect
of this is you would normally expect the
chairman of the BBC to be getting
involved expressing an opinion but he he
can't because he's under investigation
for wait for it a lack of impartiality
over both his donation to the
conservative party of 400 000 pounds and
helping Boris Johnson facilitate an 800
000 pound loan when you've got the
chairman of the BBC silenced in a
scandal like this because of his own
lack of impartiality as many see it that
really to me Henry sums up just what a
fast has been
I agree I mean peers we're football fans
we're used to dealing with VAR as fast
and this is VAR tenfold there's clearly
an inconsistency in the guidelines on
impartiality and at the end of the day
to use a football league cliche lineker
is a sports presenter he wasn't doing on
Match of the day he wasn't doing it on a
news channel wasn't doing it on a on a
news program and again we're a grown-up
country we should be able to have
grown-up debates and if the government
of the BBC are scared of a sports
presenter voicing an opinion which some
people believe in and they believe in
his principles on his own private social
media accounts then either they need to
look at those guidelines for Freelancers
within the BBC or just grow up yeah I
completely agree Richard Tice uh well
you've lost it's Linux I've been proven
absolutely
BBC and its launchers last Thursday and
I said he's brought the BBC into
distribute and he did because they had
zero Sports cover John Saturday all the
others sided with him I was proven
exactly right even Henry's just admitted
he breached the editor why is he back on
air then well hang on he breached the
guidelines he breached the code of
conduct for social media no one said
which is why he's nobody has said that
absolutely no they haven't which is what
he's sorry no sorry Richard Richard
Richard
you can't just say things without me
countering that's how we got into this
trouble in the first place the point is
they haven't found him in breach
actually they've actually allowed him
back on air on Saturday because they
recognized that they were up against it
with all the others because he's agreed
with them that all these guidelines need
a review but they haven't found him in
breach they know he breached the
guidance which which was set in 2020.
you can't keep telling me that the sky
is red when it's blue do you want me to
reread them again the the social media
guideline says you cannot tweet you
might say he's in breach the BBC in its
conclusion today has not said he was in
Bridge because the guy desperately
trying to settle the guidelines you
admit they haven't said that
the point is no the fact is
they've agreed to review the social
media guidelines because that doesn't
mean clear it doesn't mean he was in
breach well I showed you last week
you've just stated for a fact he was in
brief because he used his personal
Twitter account to give a a passion the
BBC said he was of his contract well
essentially that was why they suspended
him last but haven't now said he was in
breach Genie I mean you fill me am I
missing something yes you are no he's
not because you're not missing anything
because they're you're talking about
being in breach of the code which
applies to employees he was a actually
he's not he's a freelancer he's not
employed makes note of his daughter he's
the face no no the code is actually
different what is most surprising to the
interview I've just heard from Tim
Davies is Tiff and Davies just said so
we can get back to business as usual
business as usual is a whole problem
with the BBC and the way it's been
working is because it's not impartial I
think the the the problem is with all of
this week is that they've shown that
they're an organizational shambles the
people at the top there are biased and
shouldn't be there and to restore
credibility is really important because
all of our shared institutions National
institutions need to have people
trusting it
right but Richard at the heart of this
to me this is very straightforward given
the volume of people who appear as BBC
faces Lord sugar David Attenborough you
know Deborah meaden on Dragon's Den
Karen Brady right all these people have
been pontificating and I think they're
perfectly right but none of them are
actually BBC staff employees now here's
my distinction I think if you work as an
employee of BBC News and current affairs
you should be prohibited from expressing
any public political opinions agree
because clearly you are in direct
conflict but I I don't give a stop with
all due respect to Gary and Lord sugar
and all the others and I don't give a
stuff they all have to say about it
that's the good news about this because
basically would you agree with it no I
do agree the point is they've got
themselves into terrible history
because he brought them into distribute
and he breached their guidelines for
which he was sanctioned and didn't
appear on Saturday that's proven me
right but we look at the heat
you keep saying something which hasn't
been established why was it then why was
he if he reached their guidelines why is
suspension being immediately
no he was suspended because he made a
comments
you know this is really important look
forward suspended for preaching he was
he was he was told he couldn't appear on
Saturday and so all the others yes but
it happened in the statement today where
there is no mention of him having
breached anything that doesn't mean he
did they're now doing a big review which
is a fudge for we got into a deep hole
we've no idea how to get out of it agree
we'll put him back on there so he can
get everything back on air and then
we're going to try and work this out my
solution which is my solution as well
but it's just simply to split using
internal affairs from everything else
but in return for which right Freedom of
Choice freedom of speech I want the
freedom of choice of not being obliged
to pay the license fee for something
that I hardly ever watch that then I
think is yeah you do if you watch any
live platform any live platform on any
device you have to buy a license fee
including if you watch YouTube on an
iPad so look the reality is we should
basically say right let's have freedom
of choice freedom of speech accept the
news that's absolutely fine but I think
this is the beginning of the end of the
compulsory license are you comfortable
having a chairman of the BBC no who
agreed who donated it's ridiculous okay
and secondly you also have Tim Davey who
runs the BBC who was himself he stood as
a Tory candidate and you've got it here
I like Tim debut Andrew he's a very
smart guy
they've got themselves in a terrible
model but the point is if you breach a
company's guidelines if you bring it
into distribute there has to be a
sanction the sanction has already
happened he didn't appear on Saturday oh
by the way the customer but hang on the
customer hang on more customers watch
without him than with him hang on well
yeah we know that's just that people
would choose it's a test card run right
as I pointed out to him actually uh I
think the point dinner is that he was
not suspended for any discernible breach
of his contract stated by the BBC he was
suspended because of the incredibly
nature of what he wrote yes and I don't
agree with what he wrote but I
absolutely defend his right to have that
kind of I absolutely defend his right
and actually everybody who bangs a tape
by Free Speech should defend his right
but I just want to pick up something
Richard Daniel you're not very good at
details but let me just um tell you
something about the subscription service
really yeah a subscription service for
the BBC as most free market marketeers
go on about how are you going to make
that happen when we've got 10.7 words on
Netflix it works on Amazon because it's
not a national broadcaster he doesn't
have to be a national broadcaster I'm
sorry I actually do I do think the
license fee is an anachronism and I do
think it's finished
I'll tell you why because my sons are
all in their 20s they're just not going
to be feeling morally obliged to pay a
license they don't buy print newspapers
they're not going to pay a BBC license
no but you have to have the technology
to have a subscription you've got
Netflix what are you talking about
because the BBC needs to have something
called conditional access technology
there's 10.7 million people in this
country who will watch a BBC on Freeview
there's 10 million people who don't have
super Broadband maybe in the future we
will get there but right now you cannot
invest and convert the whole of the BBC
to Subscription Service it's not
possible at the moment we're going to
leave it there
um I think you have to accept that you
lost Richard nonsense I've been proven
right he didn't appear on Saturday he
bought the BBC into disrefute I'm right
you you were wrong on Thursday final
question for Henry Winter given you are
the doyen of football experts are
Arsenal going to win the league Henry
because it's looking good
[Laughter]
honestly the the way they've recovered
from Manchester city is just as
impressive as the way you've just put
this Richard character away Pierce
exactly why I wanted you on Henry Winter
great to see you Henry thank you very
much Richard great to see you and don't
worry you'll bounce back and great to
see you Gina thank you very much
next tonight the award for the world's
worst a-lister this is my old friend
Hugh Grant I say he should now be banned
from all award shows after his obnoxious
performance on the Oscars red slightly
beige carpet we'll debate that with
Sharon Osborne and Hugh Grant fan Bonnie
Greer next
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today
first edition is about making sense of
what's really going on Politics on the
economy and across the World At Large
music makes sense opinions that matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
foreign
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
well as Awards shows go this year's
Oscars was about as beige as you can get
even the traditional red carpet took it
replaced by a beige one but what's got
us all talking for the wrong reasons is
the ever obnoxious Hugh Grant he's
seemingly delighted and humiliating
interviewer a supermodel Ashley Graham
on the non-red carpet
what's your favorite thing about coming
to the Oscars
um
well uh
it's fascinating it's a it's a the whole
of humanity is here it's uh it's Vanity
Fair what are you wearing tonight then
just my suit your suit who made yours
you didn't make it
um I can't remember my tailor what does
it feel like to be in Glass Onion well
I'm barely in it I'm in it for about
three seconds okay all right okay well
thank you so much it was nice to talk to
you yeah all right back to you guys
I mean
[Music]
I mean it went on a bit the Hugh Grant
uh exchange there with poor old Ashley
Graham just doing a job right if you go
on the red carpet at the Oscars or the
beige garbage as it was last night it's
the biggest carpet in Show Business
history it is crawling in journalists
the only purpose of walking down it is
to talk to the media
but all Hugh Grant who hates the media
decided he wanted to present an award of
the Oscar Zone March down the carpet and
then be a complete douchebag to any
journalist who had the temerity or
supermodels to ask him questions like
what are you wearing which is probably
the most famous question in Hollywood
history to which the answer is I'm
wearing Dolce Gabbana or whatever it is
you're wearing what you don't do is
humiliate and pick on a young
interviewer just trying to do her job
yeah roll your eyes and walk away like
God have I got to deal with these idiots
well we've got talk TV presenter Sharon
Osborne has joined me and play writing
author Bonnie gribb Bonnie let me start
with you you you apparently want to
defend this Behavior well you know
Pierce look it wasn't very nice I mean I
wouldn't have done it myself you
wouldn't have done it yourself but the
guy walked up to her he's an actor I
looked at him immediately and knew he
was off cue he had his jacket open his
pot belly was showing I thought uh oh
and why is he on the carpet well I don't
know why does anybody go down you know
actually probably and you know how it is
they probably got him in the film so
they could get the film made and then he
thought let me show him to help my mates
but I really don't want to be here he
said he said to promote yeah he did he's
there to appear in front of him
and for that
it's a brand of new of you grant is to
be just what he was
don't call people dicks why not
generally what if they are a dick Janet
as good as Sharon Osborne Sharon uh
maybe I shouldn't have used the d word
but to me he just behave like a dick I
mean he just he just treated her she
Graham I felt with total disrespect and
he pretended like the job of somebody on
a red carpet if you're an actor at the
Oscars is not to talk to the media or if
you have to look like you're sucking
lemons
yeah I I have to say listen I love Hugh
Grant but he was out of order Ashley
yeah I do I think he's a great actor but
a great idea I was he plays the same
role every time he does a movie and he
did one last the other day
he plays a certainly dim witches
the thing is if you don't want to talk
to press if you are bored by it all
don't do the carpet that's the way it is
if you know you're not in the mood to
talk to press don't do it this I
completely agree now the other rule of
the Oscars because it was I gotta say I
watched it all it was long for over
three and a half hours again uh they put
back all those Awards which we thought
we'd got rid of last year for all the
production stuff which is very important
in Hollywood to people in the industry
but nobody outside of Hollywood cares
about all these little Awards which then
take up all the time but then somebody
forgot another Golden Rule Sharon which
was uh when you lose you've got to try
and pretend you're happy for the people
who win
but this is something Angela Bassett did
not get the memo on take a look
Jamie Lee
[Applause]
I mean it's like she literally was
sucking or inhaling a large bottle of
particularly toxic vinegar
um she could not contain her discussion
I are good about this Sharon is she's
supposed to be an actress I mean surely
in that moment what you do is you just
act your way out of it you pretend
you're happy but Jamie Lee Curtis don't
he
yeah it's um
I I listen I I get it the disappointment
that's why I never let Aussie go to
award shows I just won't do it you don't
want to be on camera when you didn't win
but but the thing is Hey listen she she
knew she would be on camera she she did
what she felt so you know she didn't
play the game she didn't pretend she
didn't applaud so you know she's got to
live with it she knew what she was doing
she's such an experienced actress she
knows the game yeah what do you think
you know he was sharing the same but you
know uh they're actors and I think what
happened last year was Will Smith opened
the door to reality so nobody's
pretending anymore and I have to say
when she didn't know what he was
referring to when he said Vanity Fair
I sort of rolled my eyes too yeah I know
but you can understand because the big
party at the Oscars
I just thought whoa and so he played you
grant and that's what he did okay we've
got two people who didn't get the memo
somebody who did get the memo right
iPhone because I've always felt if I
ever won an Oscar and I admit this is an
unlikely aspiration at this stage
although to remind people I have
appeared as myself in nine movies at a
grossed 2.3 billion dollars you've got
no nomination which means I've actually
grossed more than people like Will Smith
however I don't want to boast about my
movie I'm just going to get out nine
movies 2.3 million in the Box it's just
it's a statistical fact
um but if I ever did win an Oscar I
would make I just think you keep the
speech short heartfelt you thank your
mum you tell a little bit about your
journey to get there and then you melt
the Applause and go away
who won the best supporting actor for
everything everywhere all at once it's
won everything last night I thought
email one of the great Oscar speeches
we'll take a little look at the clip
here
my journey started on a boat I spent a
year in a refugee camp
and somehow I ended up here on
Hollywood's biggest stage
they say stories like this only happen
in the movies I cannot believe it's
happening to me this this is the
American dream
you know what Bonnie that right there
was the American dream yes that was a
beautiful speech yeah but what you're
not accepting
you you like the beautiful parts of the
realness of the Oscars yes and not the
ugly parts of the realness of the Oscars
and that was no no you're missing my
point I like the reality I like Hugh
Grant showing us what a Dickie is I like
uh Angela Bassett showing us she's a bad
loser because it's the truth we're not
trying to hide it yes it doesn't mean to
say that it's good what they're doing
although we can't criticize I don't know
what good means I like real and that's
what it was even when people are just
behaving graciously well well you know
some people are not like that
on on this one uh Sharon I thought this
guy uh Keith we Quan it was a really
moving speech but also that story what a
story that is he came from Vietnam his
family fled Vietnam in a boat they go to
Hong Kong they eventually come through
the refugee program into America and
there he is winning an Oscar uh and you
think about all the debate going on
right now in the UK about these people
trying to come in on boats some
deservedly some not deserved inside it
was a vivid reminder that actual genuine
refugees do need help and if they do get
the help they can live a dream like that
absolutely I mean he's living proof but
I mean that speech was so heartfelt I
mean I think everyone all over the world
was so taken and in tears by his speech
have you been to the Oscar show have you
ever sat through it
yes is it as torturous as people tell me
it is
yeah because you're thirsty and hungry
and you want to go to the bathroom wow
having worked with you for years I've
got to say I've been worked with you for
four years and America's Got Talent if
you were any one of those three things
all hell used to break leaves what was
it what was it like when all three were
the problem
it's uncomfortable it is you get
uncomfortable is it going to be
uncomfortable and I think the one of the
biggest winners of the night was Glenn
Close who was supposed to be there and
presenting an award but got covered at
the last minute and couldn't attend
which I think is the Steve McQueen Great
Escape award uh because I just couldn't
because you have to sit there it's three
and a half hours it's a ceremony but you
have to sit there Bonnie for four and a
half hours I want to escape because of
covet though they get you in an hour
before four and a half hours you sit
there no food no drink
it's a nightmare why have you been to
Canada school Catholic School yeah
that's my background no biggie no biggie
Sharon do you think on the Oscars
generally each year the ratings seem to
dip dip dip dip dip like all award
ceremonies now in a way the pandemic
sped all this up it's like are people
done with the war ceremonies are they
done with watching a bunch of very rich
very famous people telling each other
how great they are
I think that award shows now aren't
really popular at all I think they're
very passe and it's like oh another
award show another award show Here We Go
Again listen the Oscars years ago were
were fantastic and the hosts were
amazing but it just seems to have been
watered down and down and it just seems
that the hosts are reading off
teleprompter I was also struck last
night uh Bonnie there were a lot of big
stars weren't there all the ones you
normally see like Meryl Streep and all
these you know Tom Cruise couldn't be
bothered James Cameron couldn't be
bothered a lot of the really big iconic
figures in Hollywood just couldn't be
bothered to go I'm with Sharon I grew up
on the Oscars yeah I used to just every
year I wanted to be there it was
glorious they all used to go and it was
incredible everybody was there was a big
band there was music it was
entertainment there was all this now
it's like a corporate event yeah that we
just get invited to and it's very Tweed
yeah and it's very sad I've got the
answer they should have one more next
year go on Sharon
no I was gonna say Bonnie do you
remember when Billy Crystal used oh my
goodness oh my goodness David Niven when
the Streaker went off
brilliant stars who came and you really
said yes you were really anxious you
didn't know who was going to win there
were no odds put out there in the street
where you thought oh I know that movie's
gonna win and it wins you never knew
there were big bands that played off I
have the solution I have a solution it
was clearly run its course it's not
glamorous anymore right so what we
should do is kill it off and one more
Oscars next year and we just unleash
Ricky Gervais for four hours yeah and he
basically he buries it he sprayed guns
the entire room and then he has a deep
bow and that's it and we played they do
the music and he's carried off that
would be it uh Sharon great to see you
great to talk to you lovely to see you
thank you very much indeed what a bit of
a gear change now because coming next
tonight is the Fox News War reporter
Benjamin Hall used to tell me the
stories of people whose lives have been
torn about by War but last year he
became a story after being horrendously
injured in a missile strike in Ukraine
he joins me next to tell his
extraordinary story
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today
first edition is about making sense of
what's really going on Politics on the
economy and across the World At Large
make sense opinions that matter so don't
miss first edition with me Tom Newton
Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back a year ago tomorrow my next
guest was reporting from Kiev in Ukraine
it's meant to be his last ever job on
the front line Fox News correspondent
Benjamin Hall was covering the war in
Ukraine when he and his crew were hit by
a Russian missile strike that left two
of his colleagues and two Ukrainian
soldiers dead and Benjamin with horrific
injuries well he has a new book out
about these experiences called saved a
war reporter's mission to make it home
it's hit number one in the chants in
America ahead of its release here on
Thursday in Benjamin I'm thrilled to say
joins me now Benjamin great to talk to
you
um it really is because when this
happened it was such an appalling attack
and no one was quite sure about the
scale of your engines but we knew that
four other people had been killed and
frankly it's it's a miracle that you're
here at all
it is and uh I think back to that day
you know constantly and I remind myself
that still being here is the luckiest
thing that happened to me uh and as a
result we've got to be totally
optimistic every day and make the most
out of life I was the only one who
survived very badly injured I lost my
leg I lost my other foot uh eyesight and
when I was shrapnel in the eye and uh
very badly burnt but I've had a whole
year to recover a whole year to push on
through
um and I finally made it and I want to
come back and tell the story not only of
how I was injured but how I recovered
and all the incredible people who came
to evacuate me to save me
um and to bring me back uh one year on
well it is an extraordinary story I know
you've talked about this before but for
our audience you haven't heard this take
me back to that day this was right at
the the start of the war and the
Russians were trying to take Kiev what
happened
we were filming that day just outside
Kiev in a village called harenka totally
abandoned I'd been bombed to the ground
and we were just filming recording
showing what the Russians had done and
as we were making our way back to the
capital city back to Kiev we stopped at
an abandoned checkpoint and out of
nowhere the first bomb came whistling
overhead and landed about 30 feet in
front of the car we tried to get the car
backwards and um the car stalled and so
cameraman my cameraman Pierre shouted
out of the car get out of the car and
the next second the second bomb landed
right next to the car and that's when I
got a lot of the facial injuries and the
shrapnel in my face and I blacked out
and as I was sitting there unconscious
my daughter came to me I saw my
daughters right in front of me and they
said to me they said Daddy you've got to
get out of the car
and I opened my eyes I came to I crawled
I pulled myself out of the car and then
the third bomb hit the car itself that
one threw me away and I woke up a little
bit later and I was on fire badly
injured and um was lying there next to
our cameraman Pierre who at the
beginning was was still alive but there
was no cell phone reception there was no
way of telling anyone what it what had
happened and I was there for about 40
minutes with my injuries um trying to
figure out how to get home how to get
home to my family and I thought to
myself no matter what happens today I'm
going to find a way home I will do it
and then amazingly a Ukrainian Special
Forces uh car drove past it didn't see
us the first time but I crawled my way
up I pulled my way through the dirt up
to towards the road and amazingly it got
lost and the car came back and I was
ready and I had a handful of grit and
dirt and I threw it at the car and they
saw me and that was the moment about 40
minutes later that I was finally saved
and I hadn't felt any pain until that
moment the adrenaline had been kicking
in but the moment that they grabbed me
and pulled me along the floor to throw
me under the the back of that van I felt
it all all in one second it came back
and the skin all well I won't give you
the details but it was that was where
the next step began where I had to learn
how to get through it having covered war
and reported on other people who'd gone
through this kind of terrible experience
what was the reality like for you to
then be actually living it yourself
yeah it's really interesting and for
years I've seen people who have had
horrible events happen to them I've seen
people you know lose their lives and be
badly injured and I always wondered how
would I react how would it be for me
um and uh I suppose I I'm just very
lucky I from the minute this happened I
realized that we had to get through it
that I had to get through it as best I
could and that if one day for example I
could walk two steps with my new
prosthetic legs the day after that I
would walk Three Steps no matter how
much the pain was one day I would always
do more than I did the day before and um
I think you get pushed to the Limit and
you have to learn a new Strength inside
you and there were times on the
evacuation I was evacuated on the Polish
prime minister's train there was this
covert mission to come in and get me
um incredible Story by
um save our allies it's an American
group that helps evacuate people who are
who are in harm and but I remember on
that train ride out without any pain
meds having to figure out you have to
get through some of the worst pain today
and you had to figure out how you're
going to do it and I dug deep and I
thought when I thought I couldn't do it
but there has to be another level inside
you another level to grit to hold on to
realize that if you if you stick
together you can survive so having
finally gone through this myself that's
what I learned I realized that inside
all of us and I think it's true all of
us when you have to you've got to do
something no matter how hard it is you
find a way you keep doing it and you
keep being optimistic about it yeah I
mean you've got extraordinary Spirit
about this I have to say
um
what are your feelings about the fact
that four people including two
journalism colleagues died in this
attack I mean do you think about that a
lot and reflect on that and everything
every single day and I think back to
when I was lying there next to Pierre
um uh someone who was like a brother to
me I'd known him for many years and uh
you know the four others didn't die and
I think that first of all that we a have
to continue doing the job we've always
done it is essential to keep telling the
stories from inside War zones so that
people back home our viewers in our
audience they know exactly what's going
on but I also think that Pierre would
have wanted me to pick myself up and to
live just as Pierre would have done and
that is to make the most out of life go
out and help as many people as I can go
and do the best for my job and for my
family and that's what I do so I think
about him dearly I remember him closely
every single day but it gives me
strength and it reminds me never to give
up just to keep on doing it
what are your thoughts now Benjamin
about the war we're a year on now a year
on from your appalling incident but a
year on with the war is still raging uh
as brutally as it ever has done what are
your thoughts about it yeah you know I
mean in one sense like I think that
we're in an incredible position and the
Russia hasn't taken over the country but
in another sense I think we've reached a
stalemate and I just feel that what we
see at the moment is something that
could go on for years
um if Putin's aim was to tear apart the
country he's done that in a sense
um and I just think it's um the
ukrainians are holding on because of the
support that they're given by NATO by
the US the UK and other countries so uh
I think Putin at the moment is waiting
to see if that support dries up if the
the West stops giving money over the
over the coming years then he might have
another shot at it but I think we've
entered a stalemate at the moment and
the idea that there may be some peace
Accord and that this war ends anytime in
the near future that's not happening in
my opinion and what about for you
because this was going to be one of the
last times you were going to go on a a a
job like this has it made you rethink
that has it cemented your view do you
have other plans now
well you know I mean one of the reasons
I had decided to pull back was because I
have a family I have three young
daughters my wife Alicia
um they gave me the strength to get
through this but it was one of the
reasons I decided to pull back from
covering so many wars but
um I won't be heading back into war
zones myself or to the front lines but
there is an ongoing discussion at the
moment about interviewing zelenski so
whether or not a trip to Ukraine is in
the cards I'm not sure but I feel
strongly about the job itself and about
people continuing to do this be planned
be prepared know where you're going but
it's essential we keep doing it I've
covered Wars for 15 years and for the
first time ever I think in the near
future I'd rather not tell stories about
the horrors around the world like I've
done I'd like to tell stories about Hope
and optimism and the incredible people
who can pull you through because that's
what I've learned I've learned how all
that help really pulled me through
um and I would just say to everyone you
know if you know someone who's having a
difficult time reach out those little
words they mean so much and so for my
own career I think maybe initially a
segue into some really uplifting
optimistic stories first do your do your
daughters know about the involvement
they had in you getting out of that car
and surviving
well I mean I've told them that they
saved my life they're still very young
um but
they know that I came back to them they
know that we had to we were always to be
together and um I think it's a story
that we'll continue to tell them you
know obviously will talk about it
forever they've obviously known they see
the injuries every day but um
I mean they're my family they're so
special you know when nothing else
counts they count families always there
for you and that's why they're so
important
Benjamin it's great to talk to you it's
great to see you uh everyone obviously
in the whole Fox family was incredibly
worried about you it's a remarkable book
saved a war reporter's mission to make
it home is that on Thursday in the UK
this Thursday 16th of March I really
commend people to buy it it's a story of
Hope of inspiration of survival and of
the power of positive thought and I
think that that's been palpable in this
interview so Ben great to see
congratulations on the book Thank you
and the success it's having but also the
message that you're spreading which I
think is so important and I really
appreciate you coming on the show
thank you Pez I appreciate it thank you
all the best
remarkable story a remarkable man well
next tonight a Welsh Government Review
recommends tearing down statues of old
white men like Lord Nelson because they
might be offensive to the diverse modern
public just doing this kind of thing
really improve the presence or the
future or is it a load of virtue
signaling nonsense we'll talk about that
after the book
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and unsense it
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large
makes sense opinions that matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
well coming up on The Talk Gary lineker
and the BBC reach a peace deal after the
impartiality rail with the presenter
returning to match the date this weekend
and Prince Harry may come to regret his
admission that he does watch the crown
as the show recreates his Nazi uniform
scandal in the next series and Prince
Andrew's upset he's not received his
inheritance from the queen did arms all
of that at nine
thank you
welcome back to peers Welcome to our
system joined Now by talk TV's Esther
Krakow Daily Mail associate editor Kevin
McGuire and Bonnie gray has returned for
more in this show very rare event I
don't even know I was going to be a
straight out the door into the first
available cab so good exactly good to
see you
um right I want to talk first of all
about prince Andrew because it just that
just made me just laugh out loud really
this idea that he thinks SD is entitled
to a large check because the queen died
from her diary in some way after she
bailed him out we think to the tune of
11 million dollars to pay a woman he
claims he never met for making sex
assault allegations he gets to pretty
rich some might think yes the heart
weeps that he isn't getting his show of
the 650 million pound Fortune uh this
strengthens my case that he should be
given a one bedroom flat in stevenage as
opposed to Frogmore Cottage but I don't
think the king is going to listen to me
Bonnie you're the great the thing of all
indefensible Royal scandals are you
gonna try and defend this one or not no
no where'd you get that from all right
I you know back in the day people used
to retire they vanished what happened to
princess yeah they just go or you go and
do so-called good works yes you take you
know sack off and I agree with this and
you go live in somewhere and you go yeah
you help people
well that's true
or in a mission you've done something
wrong yeah well he signed an agreement
and he remember in the statement there
was some apology to the woman he'd never
met yeah he didn't know but there was an
apology of how he's he behaved now if
he's short of a few Bob he can get a job
he can get Pizza Pizza Express I can
imagine but you know but the the real
Scandal here isn't Andrew mourning grown
in revealing his self-entitement and
privilege but I want the money it is the
fact there is a 1993 agreement which
means Monarch to Monarch inheritance yes
Escape inheritance taxes yes everybody
else in the UK will pay inheritance
probably after 325 000 pounds in the
state or half a million if there's a
house involved Charles is getting 650
million quid not paying a penny but he's
expecting us to cover a very expensive
elaborate coronation in Westminster
Abbey yeah my view about this
if you're going to have a royal family
they should be treated like a royal
family with all the bells and whistles
and then you hope to recoup as they do
as they do you have to make a net profit
for all the money that comes in from
tourism
you know there's no history in this
country very little history of they were
not having Royals there always have been
the and in fact Oliver Cromwell yes it
was and Albert Cromwell no listen you
buried him with a crown so no my point
about 11 years two days two days after
your laugh which you've just erupted
again it's now the laugh that's gone
around the world due to this clip which
has gone viral literally everywhere in
the world what's happened if I can
identify anything without any need to
prove I'm actually what that is why
can't I on International women's day say
I'm Piers Morgan I'm a black lesbian I
think taking it to a kind of absurd
status I think that's something with
respect I think that you've already
opened the absurdity door by saying it
is Limitless you can do what you like
anyone can say I'm a woman so I simply
ask you why can't I I mean this point
kind of ridicules trans people to an
exception we managed beautiful to run
that clip right after the moment where
Esters
so that was a brilliant bit of editing
which managed to ruin my entire moment
so thank you everybody
um but obviously just before that when I
first said it you erupted it it's now
become the most famous cat we'll try and
get it for her off here it's become the
most famous cackle in history
I would have laughed why can't I
identify okay why can't I identify as a
black lesbian
that's the one anyway you're famous I've
got people all around the world who's
that girl where's that cackle I can't
blowing your nose before you came on
let's talk quickly about these uh this
ridiculous initiative from the Welsh
government to remove white men statues
of Duke of Wellington Admiral Nelson and
so on they must be hidden or destroyed
to create the right historical narrative
according to Welsh government guidance
Esther I think there's constant running
away from history is becoming a bit
embarrassing I don't know many people in
India that you know try and tear down
statues or mourn you know the impact of
the mughals during the Mughal Empire
it's a uniquely British phenomenon which
I find very confusing there's some I
mean what
[Laughter]
Russia and most of Eastern Europe would
still have statues all over Australian
are you kidding
them down is still one of the most
popular historical figures are you
comparing the Duke of Wellington and
Admiral Wilson to start
or even by your Twitter standards is
that what you're doing we in the UK
would still have a statue of Jimmy
Savile outside a Leisure Center in
Glasgow
Duke of Wellington and Admiral Nelson
actually they were good and bad uh
Nelson everybody
Defenders of the slave trade attempt the
watch government doesn't want to take
them all down but if you put up a statue
at someone why are we so ashamed of all
our history suddenly we're not ashamed
Churchill apparently he's gotta go now
Nelson's got to go Wellington's got to
go no he doesn't I think all the whiny
brats moaning about them they should go
body great as a museum person I do think
there's a period when a statue is not
appropriate for the Public Square but
you put them in the museums you don't
have to destroy it but keep teaching a
statue is to teach and keep teaching you
know who I want to start yours very soon
in about three months time
the manager of Arsenal outside the
Emirates Stadium
um we'll be talking about Roald Dahl and
all this editing and so on um there's
been a new burst of this in Australia
um the Australian newspaper has has
broken this story about Enya Blyton
books can you believe this the phrase is
shut up don't be an ass and don't be an
idiot have been cut from into blyton's
Famous Five this is apparently to
protect children I think that's a real
shame because it removes some really
valuable insults from children's
repertoire I took great pride in coming
up with really creative insult as a kid
what are we doing Kevin to literature
look enifflight's Famous Five don't be
an idiot yeah look I prefer leave books
as they were at the time sometimes you
might put a warning on the cover that's
fine why the two things is really in a
block go away but I got back under a
rock but the truth is these are
commercial decisions and people are
probably not buying them at the moment
one of the reasons they're not buying
them is some parents will not want their
kids to be coming across those uh those
phrases this can't be right but what's
happening well well as a writer I would
say I don't like seeing writers work uh
re-edited by people who are not them
that's my first feeling and these
ghastly new people and I have a problem
with that I really do and what can I say
but but peers I got the Christie you
would not want it to be called Tim right
would you no so there is a principle
used as with free speech there are
certain things right I wouldn't want
people to inspire hatred right this kind
of stuff is nonsense and actually it to
me it trivializes and devalues the
important debate
thank you Pat great to see you whatever
you're up to tonight Keep It Uncensored
that's the key free speech matters ask
the BBC who just lost to Gary then again
good night
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today
first edition is about making sense of
what's really going on in politics on
the economy and across the World At
Large music makes sense opinions that
matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M